[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 122 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie work hi Melanie how
are you doing I'm doing okay how are you
doing I'm doing okay before we get
started today I know you and I wanted to
just have a little personal note to talk
about the recent incident at YouTube in
San Bruno we wanted to acknowledge that
that happened and just a side note on
that usually we record our and abuse in
our rappers as we like to call them
couple days out before we launch our
podcasts on Wednesdays so we'd recorded
last weeks prior yeah we wanted to
acknowledge what happened and also the
fact that obviously these are some
serious issues that are going on in the
US as well as other locations and we
want to give our support to our YouTube
colleagues and those who have been
impacted absolutely and just as a
reminder if you need any sort of mental
health help please reach out there are
plenty of resources we'll put some in
the show notes as well and and we're
also grateful for the support that the
community has been showing to the
youtubers as well there's a lot of great
people companies images and things that
have been shared but yes mental health
is a big issue there's a significant
domestic event that still out there but
there's some great resources and support
that's coming out and we highly
recommend people reach out if they need
help okay so mark this week we have
actually a podcast interview that I'm
excited about because we got a chance to
bring in some of the folks from Project
Jupiter yep
Jessica UV and Chris who are all here to
talk to us about project Jupiter and
specifically we dive into pupitar hub as
well as binder and and just get into the
mechanics and support around that and
this is a tool or tools that are being
used specifically around the research
but they're not just for researchers so
you'll hear more about that shortly then
after that as always we do our question
of the week where we're talking about
how did Google predictions do during
March Madness which I believe is
basketball I'm pretty sure yeah I love
it you're the gamer neither of us really
know that much about sports something
out of that anyway
okay so cool things of the week yeah
let's start with your favorite okay yeah
so this is this was actually a couple of
weeks ago but is is really cool if you
hadn't known there's a new Dragon Ball Z
game coming out that's hosted on Google
cloud platform I'm gonna put a link in
the show
to the video they did at the game
developer conference presentation they
did at the Google developer day where
they talk about how they use spanner for
global consistency as well as the Google
network to enable player versus player
action around the world they show a live
demo of someone playing in San Francisco
against someone in Japan which is really
really cool with really low latency and
a really great real-time gameplay and
one of the other cool things that
they're using is bigquery and to help do
their analysis which i think is great
but it is it's pretty impressive in
terms of being able to use spanner as a
way to connect all the the different
players out there next cool thing of the
week that we want to mention is
text-to-speech which is powered by
deepmind's wavenet so texas speech is a
new API that has been developed and is
out there now on Google Cloud console
that you can use to basically convert
text to speech and they have 32
different voices from 12 languages the
nice thing is that it's running on TPU
so it takes one second of speech and can
convert it in 50 milliseconds it's got
much higher fidelity higher quality this
wavenet model that they're using is
actually something that was initially
developed and provided back in 2016 but
it's been significantly improved since
then and used first things like text to
speech so check it out nice
and finally projects that I'm actually a
huge fan of gitlab if you've never used
it at a great DevOps lifecycle tool as
well as a great place to host get 4sa in
steering company projects I've used git
lab in the past but I've never actually
been exposed so much to their continuous
integration and continuous delivery
pipeline tooling but it just got even
better in that they have a new Auto
DevOps feature which detects the
language your app is written in and
automatically builds your CI and CD
pipelines for you and particularly of
note is that they can now push really
nicely up to kubernetes either gke
cluster or an existing kubernetes
cluster in a great way that works for
continuous delivery so it's got some
great tools in it super happy with what
get labs doing okay mark I think it's
time to go talk to the group from
project Jupiter sounds good let's do it
so this week we are excited to have with
us several members of the team project
Jupiter we've got Jessica Ford UV Panda
and Chris Holt Groth welcome yeah great
to be here hi hi so I would like you all
to take a minute and just explain a
little bit more of what you do on
project you
so just why don't you start so my name
is Jessica Ford I've been with project
Jupiter for a little less than a year
and I work on a number of projects I'm
actually a cross project so I've been
working a lot with the Jupiter hub team
with UV and Chris and then I also do a
lot of my work on the blog the website
and I also work on Jupiter lab which is
our new imagination of what
communication can be like with Jupiter
notebook like interfaces and so we we
just recently announced that as well you
guys didn't look at that we're probably
not gonna be talking as much about that
but Jupiter lab is also another project
of ours we have we have actually a
number of projects and so I ended up
working on a lot of them hi my name is
UV I work at UC Berkeley right on the
technical operations for the data
science division a multi-part past
Jupiter I've been contributing them for
about two years I mostly work on
scalability stuff so that superhub
binder hub I done the big super hubs
that Berkeley uses for both they're like
local classes and their online classes
and I also do like operations for binder
hub on my binder org and then I also
like develop a lot of the cupids
integrations for both superhub and like
related projects like tasks yeah my name
is Chris whole graph I'm a fellow over
at the Berkeley Institute for data
science and I've been in the sort of
open-source data analytic world in
Python for several years now and have
sort of bumped up against the Jupiter
world over that time now I work on the
Jupiter project as a link between the
technical developments and some of the
specific use cases and organizations
that use Jupiter technology so just a
little bit of this a little bit of that
and making sure that the things that
we're building and Jupiter are matching
on to needs that people have in the
scientific in the education community so
you've all talked about what you work on
can you talk to us a little bit about
what is project Jupiter and a little bit
about its history where did it come from
because I know ipython notebooks
originated is one of the main projects
but can you tell us a little more about
all of this well okay I'll start so back
in in Colorado there was a physicist
named Fernando Paris who was working on
his PhD and he wanted to be able to
share his research with
his colleagues back home in Medellin
Colombia and was frustrated by the fact
that the software he was working with
was very expensive and was closed source
and he couldn't necessarily share it
very easily with people back home and so
he in his spare time created ipython
which is a project that still exists
today and as part of the Jupiter
ecosystem and ipython is a command-line
tool for interactive Python it is now
considered what we call like a kernel
for people to actually write code in
many other languages in fact you can
even create your own kernel we just
showed a blog post with kernels in C++
so if you want to do interactive C++ we
have interactive C++ and from there we
got more people involved we have a part
of our team also Ryan grinder who also
leads the project and this eventually
became ipython notebooks which is a tool
in the browser for interactive Python
visualization data science which now
became renamed to Jupiter because again
we are now we are actually a polyglot
open source project and so we now from
there have a number of projects related
to interactive computing open source
open standards and data science and
scientific communication which relate to
education and lots of other applications
and so some of our latest projects
binder and Jupiter have come out of that
sort of origin story yeah the only other
thing I'd add to that is that as the
technology has grown in its complexity
and the variety of uses also the
organization Jupiter itself has grown
quite a bit so it does Jessica mentioned
it originated with you know a couple of
developers on sort of you know extra
side side project kind of time but now
is a much more complex and diversified
group of people some of which are
researchers at universities some of
which are data scientists or developers
at companies and many of which are just
general open source enthusiasts who
spend their time working on these
projects so there are some core members
of the project but it has a much broader
open source community that represents
both did analytics worlds like Python or
something like this but also a much
broader spectrum of languages like C++
or JavaScript or anything else you could
imagine yes okay you mentioned a couple
of times the term in the rack
give notebook as part of the Giro
project what exactly does that mean so
an interactive notebook is a browser
interface in which a person can enter
code in this example we'll take Python
and so let's say you are a data
scientist writing Python and you have
your panda's data frame and you want to
be able to visualize it now if you
wanted to be able to get the
visualization now that you probably
would will have to do a little bit of
extra legwork to get the image out to
save it to open it up and see it whereas
in an interactive notebook things flow
together relatively seamlessly so that
if you want to create the plot the plot
shows up in the browser and so we really
try to leverage the power of the browser
to make scientific communication a part
of scientific computing is this
something that I would use standalone
just myself or is this something I would
do in partnership with say another
developer kind of Google Docs tile or
how does that flow work you could do it
either way and in fact people do do it
either way communication in a I write
something and then I send it to you or
share it to you is very very popular
people also use notebooks to write
scratch say you're trying to prototype
an idea and you want to be able to
figure out if it runs or if you like the
way the output looks to you you can do
it that way but additionally we are
actually are very interested in ideas of
real time collaboration as well today
that's something that we're working on
and thinking about in the Jupiter lab
project additionally you can communicate
to people within a certain ecosystem for
example within Jupiter hub so so these
kinds of relationships between like
communicating for yourself and
communicating with other people are very
important to us also people use it just
with github so if you could have as
millions of notebooks so people use it
just like code and get up even renders
them automatically now so that's how
they better use it I think one of the
interesting origin stories of the
Jupiter notebook actually comes from
scientific publishing so one of the
original ideas that that the then
ipython now Jupiter team had was trying
to find a way to package the sort of
static representation of your work which
in in science and academia is just
basically a PDF it's a snapshot of words
that you write and
static images that you generate but
behind those static images is a lot of
really interesting complexity and in
some sense that's the real work like the
code and the operationalization of that
code is where the rubber meets the road
so to speak and so one of the goals of
the original notebook format was to
create an interface and a way of
packaging your work so that you didn't
have to separate out the code from the
narrative and that hopefully would
create different ways that you might try
to communicate your results to other
people in ways that are only possible
when you can actively be interacting
with whatever work it is that you're
presenting to someone and we've been
really lucky in that we've had very good
uptake from the scientific community
from the academic community I think
they're in the millions of Jupiter
notebooks available on github in fact
it's now considered a language on github
although I don't know necessarily per se
because Jupiter notebook can be written
in any kind of language that we support
and we support tens of languages like
I've been in the over 100 at least
and so we have notebooks from the chief
economist of the World Bank that are on
github
we have notebooks from the LIGO project
which recently won the physics Nobel
Prize that are available on github that
we also host on binder so so there were
a lot of different interesting stuff
that's being happening I know media
companies now are sharing their data
journalism through Jupiter notebooks and
so we're we're really excited about the
ways people have been able to use it
today now you've mentioned Jupiter hub
can you explain to us a little bit more
about what that is yeah sure so a
Jupiter notebook for example assumes
that you're running something locally on
your own computer that's the most common
pattern of interaction when you're
writing code and running it against some
kernel what Jupiter hub does is it
allows you to host either on hardware
that you own or somewhere in the cloud a
server that manages multiple Jupiter
processes at the same time so it will
use a Jupiter server to have many users
simultaneously sending code to kernels
and getting the responses back from them
it's useful partially because as a
deployer of a Jupiter hub you can
specify the environment that you want
everyone to have access to you can
specify the packages the versions you
can specify data that needs to be in a
particular place so that everyone has
access to it and the goal there is that
by standardizing these things you're
creating a more consistent environment
so that people can share their work more
easily and you don't run into strange
conflicts that come from you know having
the wrong package installed or having
the incorrect version of data on some
path on your computer and the other hope
is that you can use this I should say as
a portal to shared computing
infrastructure so that people who don't
have say fancy sophisticated Hardware
themselves or maybe who don't even have
a laptop with you know a ton of RAM I
can still do fairly complicated
processing but they're doing so via the
cloud or via whatever resources the
Jupiter hub is deployed on and so I
think the goal there is that it
increases the accessibility towards
doing modern-day data analytic
interactive workflows in a way that's
only possible when you have those kind
of shared resources and when we were
talking earlier you're saying how
Jupiter hub was sort of the impetus for
why you started to engage with using
kubernetes so the when I started working
at Berkeley we had like a big-ish course
we had like what nine hundred students
at that time they were learning
fundamentals of data science and we
wanted them to use a Jupiter hub because
we didn't want to spend our time like
teaching people how to install stuff and
like they might have different kinds of
computers and then you know like
someone's gonna come up with Windows XP
and we were like to figure out how to
install Python three there so we want to
like eliminate that and then like allow
students to focus directly on like
learning data science this is also
especially important because we were
targeting groups or not just in computer
science but people from like other
disciplines and whatnot and it was like
we were running into some scaling
problems at that time and we also wanted
to be as cloud agnostic as possible we
did not want to get locked into any
specific cloud vendor we also want to be
able to run on bare metal if we needed
to and so at this point cubed is like a
very good choice for us to make because
it let us do all of this in one system
so we didn't need to have like you know
like ansible or something else that like
set up the base system and then have
like a clustering technology on top
which was like a lot more complex to
manage this was just like okay we have a
cupidus cluster we can do everything we
want on top of it and the scalability is
fairly elastic
can go up and down without too many
problems and so we were like okay let's
just like I I was already writing the
cue media syndication for Jupiter hub
for a while as a warrant here and then I
just got hired at Berkeley to do that
full-time so does that mean that you
have to have equipment IDs clustered
around Jupiter hub or is it an optional
not necessarily so Jupiter hub is very
extensible you can plug in any
Authenticator you want and the same way
you can plug in any spawner you want so
it ships with the default spawner that
just doesn't assume anything except you
have a Linux machine but then there are
spawners for like lots of popular
technology this part is just just used a
docker container
there's the cubanía spawner that we've
written and then there's just like
there's a systemd spawner there's like
lots of spawners people write them I
think one of the challenges that the
data eight-faced in particular is that
when you're designing technology for
something like science or education you
have to make assumptions that the
organizations that are going to be using
that technology don't have oftentimes as
much resources and funds to hire people
as you would if you were at a company or
something like this and I think one of
the benefits of kubernetes is that
because of the properties that people
often talk about in terms of you know
self-healing and scalability and stuff
like this you can often manage more
complex deployments with fewer highly
trained technical you know DevOps style
people and you know data 8 as you
mentioned now it's it's over
I think 1,400 students or something like
this and it has by some accounts a
relatively modest team of people who are
actively developing it and upgrading it
and maintaining it over time and my
intuition is that that's something that
would be much more difficult to do if
you were using other kinds of you know
cloud deployment approaches so I know
when we first were talking about doing
this podcast Jessica you were telling me
about binder and I know binders built
off of Jupiter hub so can you tell us a
little more about binder and what it
does and why it was built yeah so I'm
I'll start with the story of binder so
binder originally started as a project
that was out of janelia farm and it was
a project to share notebooks in a
curated manner so that you had notebooks
that had a similar idea or a similar
narrative story to come together in
in one cohesive piece and so the current
set up we have now is the version 2.0 of
binder which is a publicly available
service for github repos to share with
the public in a way that it has the
entire environment set up so that you
would go to a specific URL and you are
launched in a docker container and that
ends up giving you the opportunity to
work with the repo with everything
already pre-installed it's a similar
experience to the things that the data
eight students are getting but in this
case you are getting specifically the
repo that you are looking at it from
github and this is particularly
interesting for applications in science
and education also people who are
creating new libraries and want to show
it up in fact that's what we use to show
off Jupiter lab we ended up using binder
and said if you want to try out Jupiter
lab here we have it right now you just
click on the URL and you are taken to
the user interface of Jupiter lab you
don't need to install anything here it
is play with it see how you like it so
that's particularly interesting for us
because it's a different way for us to
interact with the public providing open
source as a service for us to share
scientific data science repositories
through github and in fact binder is
actually a number of projects that are
connected together there are modular
pieces Jupiter hub is actually one of
them and the other major pieces under it
are repoed a docker the binder server
itself and then we also have front ends
such as Jupiter notebooks our studio and
Jupiter lab it's worth highlighting that
binder was originally created by the
group of a researcher named Jeremy
Freeman and it was also open source
technology it was running online in the
cloud and it performed what Jessica just
described you know being able to share
an interactive data analytic environment
with a single link and because that
project was open-source the Jupiter team
started having conversations with the
the the first incarnation of the binder
project basically realizing that a lot
of the complexity of the tooling in
binder 1.0 call it was doing a lot of
this stuff that Jupiter hub handles very
flexibly and very nicely
and so there was kind of a realization
that well what if we could just make
binder a particular configuration of a
deployment of a Jupiter hub and add one
extra component which is the ability to
automatically generate your computing
environment on the fly so that people
can specify their environment just via
random text files in their github
repository rather than requiring people
to you know craft a docker image on
their own so those projects kind of
fused together into in a collaboration
that's been going on for about a year or
so now but a lot of that initial heavy
lifting we're all very thankful to the
original binder team for and I know when
we were talking about binder the reason
behind driving out building up behind
her - or part of the reason was you know
you've got so much great content and
research that's being done in the
scientific community and there was a
desire to be able to make it easier for
people to run that kind of content and
run that without having to recreate it
from scratch yeah I mean I think that
one of the points of friction in
scientific research is being able to
reproduce or being able to work with the
scientific computation pipeline that is
in a particular paper so for example the
LIGO project is probably our most famous
research institute who has their
research available and binder they have
a demo that allows people to get
immediate access to their data which is
gravitational wave data and show people
basic signal processing methods so that
you can reproduce their study and
basically find the gravitational waves
that they got the Nobel Prize for if
people did not necessarily have access
to binder it would be less interactive
one would have to figure out how the
dependencies were set up install
everything from scratch and tried to
piece together all the different parts
of the repo to understand how to
reproduce this result whereas with
binder and also Jupiter notebooks it
becomes a seamless interactive notebook
that has everything pre-installed and so
you can walk yourself through the
thinking of the scientists and
understand how they conduct their own
research yeah the way that I like to
think about this is there's in my mind a
difference between making your work
technically open and
DuSable versus making it practically
open and reproducible and a lot of times
you'll see people just throw a bunch of
code and maybe some description of the
environment needed to run that code onto
the web somewhere and while it is
technically possible that you could go
through all of the different steps of
trying to figure out what it is was
going through the author's head when
they put all of this there the vast
majority of people aren't going to take
the time to you know clone a repository
pull it onto their computer install all
the packages that are needed get the
data into the right place you know spin
up their own session start stepping
through debug problems when they come up
most people just won't do that but if
you could do something like share the
ability to interact with that repository
just via a single link that someone
clicks and they can immediately start
getting up and running I think that the
barrier to entry there is low enough
that people will actually start doing it
and then you can do different kinds of
things in terms of designing your
content when you're assuming that others
are going to be interacting with it and
we recently presented some work at the
fairness accountability and transparency
conference in New York with regards to
accountability and transparency and
machine learning research although we
believe this extends to all different
kinds of scientific research and data
science in general but the the
interesting distinction I think and when
we think about what binder does is that
historically when people were thinking
about reproducibility they wanted to be
able to to independently validate what
happened in a scientific study doing it
in their own laboratory or their own
environment we're basically trying to
replicate the environment of the
scientist as much as possible with
modern computational methods so it is as
if the laboratory is opening the doors
the public and allowing people to walk
in and says these are our tools this is
what we did and you can you can use
these tools as if they were your own so
it's kind of an interesting distinction
and I think that's part of the reason
why we think about it even as an
accountability and transparency project
because this the distinction is actually
that you're not necessarily reproducing
it in that it's not a separate thing it
is the exact same environment as the
scientist that is producing this
research awesome this sounds really
great so if I'm sitting down
and I'm doing some research and I have
this data set that I'm doing research on
and I'm thinking to myself I want to get
this out on binder where do I put my
data what is that development pipeline
look like how do I get that sort of
thing set up so one of the goals of
binder is to try and piggyback on
pre-existing tools and the open source
ecosystem as much as possible and what
that means is that the Delta the amount
of energy that's needed to make a
repository quote/unquote binder ready is
pretty small
what binder does is when you give it a
URL to a get repository and that could
be something on github or gitlab or
whatever you put your code as long as
it's publicly available it's going to
check out the repository and it looks
for what are called configuration files
and by that what I mean is if you're a
Python developer requirement txt or
environment yeah mol if you're a Julia
developer capital require file
it also looks for things like apps dot
txt files to specify apt packages and
the goal of this is to infer the
environment that's needed from text
files that are already part of the
workflows for people from those various
communities and so from the author's
perspective if you want to make your
repository interactive via something
like binder all you need to do is make
sure that those text files are there in
either the root of your repository or in
a folder and the root of your repo
called binder binders then just gonna
automatically look through those files
and whenever it finds them it generates
a docker file that says ok I need you
know this version of numpy installed and
this version of matplotlib installed it
then generates a docker image from that
docker file and registers it online and
then binder knows how to ask for certain
images based on the links that different
users are clicking on so in many cases
you don't actually have to do anything
if you've already sort of followed best
practices in scientific computing you've
already included you know an environment
UML file with your repository in many
cases all you need to do is just give
that URL to binder and it'll do the rest
and where do I put my data like
especially if I have very large sets of
data where does that go to go on my
github repository I think that if you
ask 10 different people you would get 10
different responses to that
the examples that we've seen so far
generally use smaller sets of data
because the amount of computational
power we have is rather limited so the
work that we've done so far on showing
how people can use binder have been on
projects where the size of the data is
relatively limited in the amount of
computation that a person is finally
using at the tail-end is limited so we
won't necessarily be able to reproduce
on binder a study that used an entire
server farm for example but if you do
have these pieces and parts the
computation then since it is interactive
can be modified so for example in the
the write-up we had for the Fitness
accountability and transparency study we
took a h-hi paper that had relatively
simple experiments computationally they
weren't expensive and we said okay let's
try modifying this experiment and seeing
how this works which is actually very
interesting because in a lot of studies
you are given this is what we did it's
done there it is but the way binder
works because it uses interactive
computing and it has the same
environment it says now that you have
this tool this model this idea it we
give you the ability to interact with
the research in a way that people
haven't been able to do online in a
publication like experience which is
particularly interesting I think because
it allows people to be able to think
beyond what the researchers are simply
telling you and work with the repo in a
way that you might want to be able to
work with it on your own that you didn't
necessarily weren't able to do it
because it required so much to like work
to get to that point but is it built to
be able to work with server firms I mean
is it built to be able to hook into that
kind of yeah ultimately uses Jupiter hub
to do to actually run your code and
super hub can like hook into anything
you want
so right now because we run it as a free
public service we put limits on like how
much RAM you can use and all of that but
you can set up one for your own
institution or whatever and then give it
as much resources as you want running on
whatever kind of infrastructure you need
so you could for example just configure
your superhub to use I think there is a
Google cloud VM spawners and then
everyone basically gets one entire
machine or you can just configure it to
like ok everyone gets like an instance
group that can scale up and down as they
want yes and then to your question mark
you can integrate with any kind of data
repositories that exist out there yeah
yeah it's just a matter of like what are
you doing your code I know for example
that is the Pangaea project they are NSF
funded project that tries to make a
central platform for people to do earth
sciences and so they store all their
data in like GCS Google Cloud storage
and so they have like fuse drivers that
let them get data directly from GCS and
the UK Met Office has something similar
but they are an s3 so they get the data
out of s3 and this is all like agnostic
Jeju perhaps we don't actually care how
you do this actually also one of the
earliest users of Jupiter hub for
scientific computing and research is
actually the labs in the Department of
Energy they end up doing a lot of high
performance computing and they have a
lot of scientists who aren't devs ops
people who aren't necessarily the most
sophisticated when it comes to running
complex jobs and they want to be able to
have as lightweight of an experience as
possible when Jupiter hub was a really
great way for them to have access to
really powerful Jupiter notebooks is
this only meant for the scientific
communities or have you seen use cases
outside so I don't think it's only been
for some commuting like so I came into
this from Wikimedia mint so where it's
like a very like Oh free knowledge
everyone should be able to participate
and so I was at the time helping run
like this thing called 2 labs which is
we provide free compute for people who
want to do things with Wikimedia data so
for example a lot of the anti vandalism
bots run here a lot of the statistics of
run here but we required people to SSH
in and then use like grid engine and
there was complex it was like excluding
a lot of people so from our perspective
at the time we were like we wanted more
people to be able to access our data and
do things with it and so a good solution
was jus perhaps so that's where I
actually start working the Cuban II
stuff because we had a cube in this
cluster and we're like okay let's put
super hub on this so we can securely
provide access to our data to people so
we provide access to our dumps but even
to our like
my SQL database which was live we like
enacted all the sensitive information
and give you people access to that and
that's something you cannot do on your
own computer right like because that's a
data store that's only available there
it's really large
it's like updated in real time and
there's I think like four million edits
or something that people are made from
that jibra hub so that's I think a very
good use case and I think there's more
people doing things like that I think I
think it's worth highlighting again
because I think this is actually related
to your previous point to the goal of
the Jupiter ecosystem is to build open
source building blocks that can be
composed and used for whatever use case
you might have in mind and so sometimes
that is doing scientific research
sometimes that is teaching a class
either at the university level or even
at the you know elementary school and
middle school levels sometimes it means
providing an interactive environment to
connect with some resources or hardware
that would otherwise be very difficult
to connect to like what you've you just
described with the Wikipedia data set
and related then to your question about
storage our goal the Jupiter project's
goal is not to create completely tightly
integrated you know full stack solutions
our goal is to build pieces that can be
put together in order to accomplish some
goal and so what I would say when when
people ask you know how is Jupiter hub
going to handle large-scale storage part
of my answer is well we don't really
have to we just need to make sure that
when there's another open tool that
exists that makes that possible that
it's easy to integrate that into the
sort of Jupiter hub binder workflow do
you have any features functionality that
are up and coming that are in the future
of Jupiter binder project Jupiter in
general we have lots anything that you
want to toss is good so one thing that
we've been working on is I scale so
we're trying to get up to 50,000 active
users at a time spanning multiple Cube
Nagi's clusters and multiple hubs but
all presenting to the user as one so
that's like when one area we will like
put a lot of work into it at the moment
we're also like on the binder side I
think something that we did like fairly
recently and it's not super public is we
added hearts through your support
because I think a lot of people in the
art community they prefer using our
studio rather than cheaper notebooks and
so we wanted to be able to like you know
we don't want to force people to switch
tools just because they want to use us
severely okay let's make the genican off
so that people can use our studio or
whatever else it is that they don't want
to use I think that another interesting
like future direction for development
you just described what would often be
described as scaling outwards so we're
just trying to get more and more and
more users for a given Jupiter hub
deployment but especially in more
sophisticated data science teams or an
academic research scientific research
you do need access to non-trivial sized
data sets or you need access to high
performance clusters and things like
this
and so I think that there's going to be
a push of development towards connecting
Jupiter hub or something like binder
with more sophisticated hardware or more
sophisticated you know cloud
infrastructure for doing computations
and analyzing data on that hardware and
I'm excited to see the different kinds
of of uses that people come up with it
as the ecosystem of tools that are kind
of natively running in the cloud
continues to develop further I also want
to say one of our biggest new features
is more documentation I think it's now
than it was like six months to a year
ago
Jessica Chris and Carol willing who's
not here have been doing a great job of
like making sure that like you know like
the only information is not in some chat
somewhere or like hidden up in someone's
brain but written out in ways that like
a diverse group of people can actually
understand and reuse in their own
contexts I know what has it been like
working on an open-source project for
all of you and it sounds like multiple
in some cases I've been working on
openness projects I I was working at
gnome when I was like 19 and I was
working at like Wikimedia so I mean that
I don't know what it is like to not work
so I'm kind of an outlier but like
Jupiter is the first project that I'm on
that's like
partially based in academia so that's a
little like different and it's also like
a much more smaller project like when I
joined when I started working with media
I was already like very big how is it
different I think it's a smaller project
you have more responsibilities to be
kinder to everyone then you have at a
larger project now I'm not saying that
it's okay to be like mean to people at a
larger project but I think if you are
person 40 in a project or person 16 a
project then you have more
responsibilities than if your person 800
at a project
800 the culture is already sort of set
changing that is going to be an uphill
battle and it's gonna be hard while if
you're at a smaller prison project then
you it's much easy to set so if you are
not careful then you can set it in ways
that you don't want it to be so I think
that's like the biggest difference
there's technical differences of course
when I was at Wikimedia I was like the
16th person to join the ops team and I
was the least experienced person doing
that while here I think like most people
don't have that much ops knowledge
because they come through like us like
grad students and whatnot so that was
also like a big difference for me but I
think related to that from from my
perspective one of the most exciting
things about the Jupiter project and
probably open source in general is that
because of the open nature of the
project you get a lot more voices in the
room and you get a lot of representation
from different kinds of background in
the room so I think it's amazing that I
get to work on you know a team of people
some of which are heavily ops oriented
and have an incredible background in you
know kubernetes some of which care about
things like documentation and community
growth and and the more social aspects
of open-source some of whom are more you
know domain scientists you run analytics
and python or an r that wouldn't be able
to deploy it you know kubernetes cluster
by themselves being able to coordinate
that kind of chaotic diverse group of
people in a way that you can create
tools that are truly community driven
and also available for all kinds of use
cases is a really satisfying thing and
in some ways is in my mind the primary
goal of the academic and education and
scientific community is creating public
goods that people can then build on for
whatever purpose they have in mind how
do you coordinator how does that get
coordinated I think that each sub
project has their own subculture and
their own sub methods and so that
largely determines how it works so
actually like for example for me I
belong to I think like five different
Jupiter project organizations a lot of
people don't even know that we have
multiple repos I think we have over a
hundred we have at least five or six
organizations and so each organization
has their own norms and culture but we
we actually share the same code of
conduct so at the higher level you know
like values norms
things like that are shared and we have
a governance repo if you want to spy on
how we were quits all available to the
public in fact all our meetings are
available to the public we put them
online on YouTube so our big weekly
meetings are every Tuesday morning 9:00
a.m. Pacific you can watch us online but
each individual project that has their
own sub norm so for example there's a
monthly meeting that we have with the
Jupiter hub and binder group Jupiter lab
meets every week and we we have a
one-hour meeting once a week but each
you know some some groups just mostly
work through the mailing list and the
issues and so it's all like a
combination of all these things I guess
one of the things that we probably
haven't mentioned enough that we
probably shouldn't say more is again we
are an open source project and so
anybody can basically jump in at any
time and so we we really try to do that
and I think that's also a lot of what I
do is I basically try to Tom Sawyer
people into saying do you like Jupiter
you can work for us too and and
basically I get them to do my work for
me but really it actually it's something
that's very very important as in fact
we're having a community day I think the
25th of August in New York which is a
free day for anyone who wants to show up
or if you just want to show up on the
internet we will be actively working on
issues that's community related and we
follow github norms of marking issues as
first issue or Help Wanted so those
things are particularly standard but
again like the broader that like sort of
others kinds of implementations are
slightly different from Dino team and
then were there any resources that you
wanted to mention regards to in regards
to Jupiter hugged you put a notebook we
were talking about some of the classes
that are out there yeah where would
people go if they want to learn about
these projects so I think that in terms
of sort of examples of particular
deployments of Jupiter hubs for
particular use cases if you go to data
eight o RG just data then the number
eight org that is a public-facing
version of data eight which is this
major course at UC Berkeley that UV has
been working on and that has driven a
lot of the technical infrastructure
particularly on the kubernetes side of
Jupiter hub there's also my binder org
is the public service
version of binder so as Jessica
mentioned binder hub is open source
technology that anybody could use for
whatever purpose they want to deploy a
binder server my binder org is a kind of
technical demonstration and and a free
public service where as a user you can
begin to interact with that and create
shareable public links for your code
repositories and then from a developer's
standpoint or from like a deployer
standpoint the best way to learn how to
deploy Jupiter hub on kubernetes is that
there's a guide called zero to Jupiter
hub which you can find at Z 2jh Jupiter
org and on the flip side for binder hub
there is a guide to deploying binder hub
on kubernetes at binder hub read the
docs Co also I should probably mention
another project on the second we have
repo to docker and that is also under
the github organization Jupiter hub a
lot of the projects we've been talking
about have been under the github
organization Jupiter hub so if you go to
github.com slash Jupiter hub you'll see
a number of our projects and repo to
docker is one of them which is also
particularly useful if you want to take
a github repo and turn it into a docker
file or something that can be easily
used and shared in that kind of format
this is great well I I really appreciate
all of you coming and talking to us
about project Jupiter Jupiter notebook
superhub and and binder anything else
that you wanted to talk about before we
go I just want to say if you know
cubanía days or want to learn more about
it then you should come and talk to us
because there's a lot of things that
we're doing on top of it and having more
people do that would be great and you
will have lots of impact lots of people
will use your stuff actually one other
thing a follow-up to your previous
question if you just want to get
involved in the community of the Jupiter
community more broadly we have a gator
channel for pretty much all of the major
projects so there's a binder Gator
channel and a Jupiter hub Gator channel
there's also a gator channel for most of
the other components that we've talked
about in this interview and we're also
pretty closely monitoring issues and
mailing lists and also a lot of just
community groups that are scattered
across cities all over the world so we
try to be as well
coming and inviting a community is
humanly possible and we would love for
whoever is listening this to get
involved well great well thank you again
I'm so glad you all were able to come to
join us today thank you yeah thank you
so much fantastic
well again Thank You Jessica UV and
Chris we really appreciate you coming
onto the podcast and telling us all
about project Jupiter telling us about
Jupiter hub and behind her and all that
and also just hearing about how
kubernetes is being used in the project
as well that was fun
yeah thanks so much for joining us a
super interesting project really great
to see that kind of collaborative
development platform getting built and
having people use it it's pretty awesome
all open-source sources the best okay so
question of the week I'm gonna ask you
yeah yeah
how did Google's predictions do during
March Madness so actually let's set some
context I know
March Madness big basketball there we go
yeah basketball tournament Google cloud
is a sponsor and there's a bunch of
machine learning stuff that was put in
place to see if we could predict who is
gonna win and who is gonna lose that's
right and there was also a cowgirl
competition that's been going on to
allow others to run their own prediction
models and see how effective they were
in March Madness but Google did do its
own separate prediction model and worked
hard at trying to be able to come up
with real time predictions too because
during March Madness apparently during
like the halftime they would take the
data from the first half and feed it
into the model and come back with
predictions prior to the second half how
cool during the final four there was a
couple of halftime ads that were even
generated within like the halftime show
to then show what they thought the
predictions were and apparently they had
a prediction we're loyal versus Michigan
we're playing and they predicted 29
rebounds and they were right and then
they also predicted during Villanova and
Michigan that at least 21 3-pointer
attempts would be made and the final
count was 24 so anyways it was really
interesting and and there's a blog post
that helps give some insights in terms
of how the prediction model was built
and this is actually something you would
do with typically any kind of data
science project in terms of figuring out
what type of data you need then building
out the pipeline that you're going to
need to feed the data and build out the
model and train it
then deploying it into production and so
they had this model they trained off of
200,000 discrete files from a decade of
NCAA basketball data there's they
apparently engineered over 800 potential
features and then applied variance and
univariate statistical tests and they
built out their models using these more
standard regression and classification
techniques and when the games were
actually playing they were updating
their entire game state every two
seconds and including all play by played
data and they were using cloud spanner
to help with this kind of processing
that they needed to do as well as
bigquery so like I said there's a blog
post we're gonna include that blog post
so that you can see how specifically
they actually engineered their
prediction models how it was deployed
and it'll give you some great insights
to think about and when you're doing
your own type of data analysis data
prediction modeling and yeah it's kind
of cool that's cool what the results
look like it's kind of cool how they
built it and congrats to the team nice
awesome all right Melanie before we wrap
up today are you going anywhere do
anything cool yes I will be speaking at
tectonic ax actually this week on the
11th and I'm gonna be talking about AI
and then actually this weekend on
Saturday I'm gonna be speaking at the
Harker research symposium on the 14th
participating in a panel to talk about
diversity and inclusion yes mark what
about you so I'm not going anywhere but
I did just start something really sad
it's fine I I was very focused on the
economy's launch and Game Developers
Conference which means I need to wrap
back up but in the meantime I've started
doing something really cool that I'm
really excited about it okay I've
started streaming the work that I'm
doing on the carnies development nice
thing so if you're into game development
and you're interested in like patents
and strategies for scaling multiplayer
games it could be interesting but if
you're in the kubernetes and you want to
look at like custom resource definitions
or controllers or on Friday last week I
was doing some helm integration that
kind of stuff you might find it
interesting as well so we'll put the
link in the show notes to chuck TV slash
mark Mandal I'm doing Tuesdays at 9:00
a.m. Pacific on a regular basis but also
trying to do a lot of little ad-hoc
sessions as well you're doing all kinds
of shirts now yeah it's fun ID so much
actually streaming coding is
delightfully wonderful well that's great
and
as far as I know it mark you and I are
working on trying to make sure that we
do an actual interview on uh con us so
hopefully that'll be coming up soon yeah
as soon as we can sort out some of the
logistics I should get on that that
would be fun cuz your schedules pretty
busy awesome
well Melanie thank you so much for
joining me for yet another podcast Thank
You Marc and thank you all for listening
and we'll see you all next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]